welcome to cbs this morning we're going
to begin with the urgent new efforts to
fight the pandemic which
dr deborah burks is now calling the
worst event
in american history think about that for
a second california is mostly
back in lockdown mode this morning with
an order affecting 30 million people
there it's a first date to lock down
again
hospitalizations in that state have
tripled in the last month
california recorded more than 30
thousand new cases in a single day
yesterday that is the highest single day
total in
any state so far and many other states
are seeing a troubling spike
our lead national correspondent david
begneau is in reno nevada david good
morning to you
what's the situation there well tony
nevada now leads the nation when it
comes to the number of people who are
hospitalized
with covid on a per capita basis and
here at renowned regional medical center
look at what they have had to resort to
they're putting patients in their
parking garage
this is a coveted ward now we're nowhere
near the patients
but they set this up back in april
hoping to never have to use it but they
started running out of space at the main
hospital
and so this is what it has come to you
know when pictures of the parking garage
first surfaced
a couple of weeks ago some people
suggested it was fake so we called them
and said can we see it and they said
come on over
we'll show you just how real it is
look at this where cars would normally
be parked there are now patients
265 have come through this field
hospital in just the last three weeks
when you have to resort to a parking
garage you know things are pretty bad
that means this is real dr jacob
keeperman had just started his job here
as an icu doctor three weeks ago
when he tweeted a picture of the parking
garage turned field hospital
right before patients arrived now some
on social media seized on the empty beds
suggesting it and the pandemic were fake
and one of those posts was retweeted
by president trump it was sad
disappointing and frankly insulting
the rampant spread of misinformation
across the country
is complicating efforts to control the
pandemic that's according to dr debra
burks of the white house coronavirus
task force
i hear community members parroting back
those situations parrying back that mass
don't work this is not just the worst
public health event
this is the worst event that this
country will face
to california now where rising
hospitalizations led to more regional
lockdowns
sunday night by order of the governor
this affects more than 30 million people
starting today salons are closed
retailers are under strict capacity
limits
and all dining indoor and out is
suspended through christmas
if i'm not open by february i will no
longer be here
my restaurant cannot open for for to go
restaurant owner angela marsden
is among those pleading with state
leaders to change their rules
after she noticed an outdoor dining tent
for a film
crew 15 feet away from her now closed
outdoor patio tell me that this
is dangerous but right next to me
as a slap in my face the way it works in
los
angeles is that county officials
classify video production work
as essential and require regular covet
testing at tv and movie shoots
back here in nevada where we are this
morning casinos and restaurants have a
25
capacity limit nurse janet baum says her
hospital which is the only one servicing
100
000 square miles has never been busier
than it is now
never in my wildest nightmares how would
i ever have thought that we would ever
see something
that would be killing this many people
janet works here at renown regional
medical center which services not only
northern nevada but part of northern
california
and even idaho this hospital is central
to this area and now they're using
a parking garage because they run out of
room one more thing before we go the uk
is set to start injecting people with
their coronavirus vaccine
as soon as tomorrow and anthony later in
the week the fda should give us an
update on the pfizer vaccine and if all
goes well they could get approval
within two or three days after that yeah
fingers crossed david thank you